all right yeah let's just go live all
right
hello
are we live right now are we live right
now guys it's up to you let us know i
mean what's going on rejected nation
welcome to our suicide squad live stream
yeah
that's how you do it yeah
all you got to do is just let us know
if you can hear us and as long as we're
good from there and from there we can
just uh proceed
absolutely i know we are one minute late
hello cuppa joe it's okay this was the
most smooth setup we've had
in theory it's a good thing you showed
up an hour early to do it john it's good
i ran two private tests beforehand it
was so good i'm so happy for you wow i'm
not frantic at all in figuring out the
settings today
hello xander reel hey olivia christopher
larson hey we've only been live for a
couple of minutes josh bendy lisa luther
oh
really quick really quick i put out a
poll yesterday on our community page
and uh yeah we haven't been on a live
stream in so long i know it's it's i've
forgotten how to do it it's not like
riding a bike i've been on like campia's
live streams more often than i have been
live on this channel lately
all right so i put out a lot a poll
yesterday thank you to everyone who's
popping in here and uh we got 12 000
votes i said um you know in the meantime
tell us what you thought of the movie
had four rankings loved it hated it
liked it didn't like it john you want to
read them off yes all right let's go uh
let's go from the bottom up six percent
a whopping six percent of people who
answered did not like the movie
then we go up to 21 of people say they
liked it it's pretty good uh three
percent hated it
smallest factor but you know a
significant one and uh the whopping
majority the vast majority with 71
percent of people saying they loved it
well it looks like from here in total
you have a 92 recommendation out of 12
000 votes absolutely that's a good sign
that's a good sign that's at least a
good sign that it's better than the
previous movie but what's kind of been
bumming me out a little bit is that i've
been hearing that the box office is not
so hot on this film
um
maybe because it's on hbo max right now
you know
it could be uh thank you alice alessio i
i these are my harley quinn braids for
the day awesome good to hear
but you guys can hear us right all right
cool
all right well let's kick this off let's
just start talking about it this this
will be you guys driving the spoiler
talk obviously you guys sending in
questions and stuff whenever we do
spoiler reviews i'm constantly like did
we talk about the thing that we were
supposed to talk about because i'm
always a little bit nervous about that
then we end up talking for too long so
it's just easier to see what the people
really want the the loyal reject
followers and if you're not loyal but
you just want to talk [ __ ] on suicide
squad you're here or whatever you just
want to be harvested happy spoilers to
ruin your friends time
um so john who in this movie was your
favorite character
who would you have to vote if i had to
pick a favorite character in this movie
right now
i've seen it twice now
and i'm oddly
uh torn really heavily right now i'm
going to say rat catcher 2. okay with a
blood sport real close second okay which
is funny because earlier it would have
been a different answer but having seen
it again
and having a different sort of an an
enhanced emotional experience yeah i
think uh you know even though there are
a lot flashier characters and obviously
you got to look like polka dot man and
stuff like i i something about rat
catcher 2 like really bonded with me so
i will say rat catcher 2 and this is not
a
structured spoiler talk we're going to
be all over the place okay
i would say that rat catcher 2 is the
one who surprised me the most yeah um i
had a feeling if you watch her trailer
reactions i had said several times that
i have a feeling she's going to be like
a hero in this film you just kind of get
that vibe with the way the trailers are
marketing her and those like because the
shows are so fast cut then you pick up
on like little lines of dialogue they
would flash to the dialogue between um
bloodsport and rat catcher on the bus
yeah i'm like i have a feeling they're
setting up that she's gonna be like
the hero in this yeah
and uh yeah when she has the moment
after that scene with tycho ytd or her
dad
and then it cuts to her
holding the light and the tears
streaming down her face both times i've
seen it i start to cry it's the only
moment that makes me like tear up in the
movie and it it's that and hearing some
people
kind of criticize the way that
flashbacks handled like it's a little
too cheesy but i don't know i like it
with the tone i personally enjoyed it
yeah and then having again on on second
viewing i thought it played even better
it played even more smoothly into just
how the visual language is set up and
what the characters are doing and what
it's doing for the development of the
characters yeah i like that i see people
in the chat really mentioning milton
i thought that milton joke was handled
wonderfully yeah i thought that was a
great bit and coming back with like you
we had a whole three-hour conversation
about your name's milton
great because that line delivery you
actually i love because i thought the
original bit about milton dying was so
funny yeah when you first see idris
elba's face and you don't really know
what he's about to say next yeah the
last what him saying like milton was
with us
what was he gonna do and i loved like
this time i think i noticed it the first
time but it hit that much harder is when
they do the rain walk and you see in the
furthest back on the far right of the
screen milton is doing the slo-mo walk
part of the team he's like uh what's
what's the guy's name in deadpool 2
rob delaney's character oh god what is
his name yeah guy who jumps out of the
plane with them yeah he's there
yeah i forgot his name he's that guy
in this movie
uh but the joke following it when after
they've won the day
and then they're like talking about
flag's death and he's like he was my
friend
uh i could be your friend too milton
yeah
you just don't see that joke coming yes
and it's perfectly planted from the
earlier bit and it's hilarious
absolutely out of the characters
personality rather than it just being
like let's shove a joke here yes
um okay so let's go right here the
weasel part was funny let's talk about
the beginning here because that's
something that i think uh
uh could be
i don't really know what's divisive here
about this movie i know some like i know
tyrone magnus didn't really like it i
know beyond the trailer didn't really
like it and i know like jeremy johnson i
know most people love this movie or
really like it a lot
um and i'm not here to like
specifically take on anyone's opinion
you know
but i do encourage you guys in the chat
to leave down your honest thoughts here
and i i see all you guys who have
submitted to our super chats already and
thank you so much yeah we do have super
chats and we also have the stream labs
open and we'll get to those in a second
we just thought we'd earn our way to
that discussion first to warm you guys
up you know fluffy even though a lot of
you guys probably like no get to the
chats
do it um
the beginning i think the intro is so
wonderfully executed i'm trying to
understand
the
choice of someone's been asking about
james gunn's direction here both times
i've seen it every once in a while a
director chooses a very specific shot
and you're like why did they choose that
shot but you know the opening shot when
you're on uh savant and then it's like a
reflection on the it's yeah it goes
upside down yeah i don't know the choice
of that
well i mean what do you interpret that
choice as i mean i feel like you're
you're yeah meeting your character
through a really dirty lens which is
kind of how everybody sees these
characters and i think what's
interesting about centering the
introduction the the prologue around
savant is like
it does
take you from your impression of him and
especially your impression of michael
rooker like talk about a unique like a a
clever choice of casting because once
you get you know through the whole
process of onboarding you see how like
nasty everyone's treating him you're
like yeah that that reflection of him in
that puddle and the sort of upside down
twist to get here sort of to me was just
like a nice tonal way of going like this
is how everybody sees me and this is
what the twist of life has done and then
by the end of the prologue he cracks and
and freaks out and like the reality of
how like
insane this all is and like the humanity
sets back in and so i feel like it's a
contrast of that and then he dies face
down in a puddle you know and so it's
like there's so many like great little
visual things that tie back around and
also have some kind of you know
interpretive character element and
that's sort of what i got from that and
even you know with the bird coming back
and eating off his carcass yeah i think
that's a good little short story yeah
like a short story about team one yeah
yeah and i mean you start off with he
kills the bird and then the bird gets to
eat off of him and it's like it's not
the same bird obviously yeah but a bird
just like it in the circle of life but i
i personally that was really well said
by the way i thought i thought you
actually
executed
the purpose of the opening shot so well
the thing though is like you like yeah i
don't know
what i would say is uh the the opening
of this i think where some people this
is where i think some people might be a
little disappointed and i did talk to
some people who i know were let down by
it especially when they see the
advertisements for it they hear uh
nathan fillions in it as tdk
uh you know you got pete david you got
some known people in here uh here's the
floor floor
um here's javelin
and i think the opening is great because
it immediately sets up the tone that
anyone can be offed here and i thought
that's why it works so well to actually
off boomerang right at the very top of
the film because he's a returning
character and then and you that's the
only one where i was hit with a feeling
of a bit of a bummer because he's one of
the few characters i liked from the last
suicide squad movie
and that is also a great way to show you
that hey one of the main characters from
the last one even though they're very
much on wrecker with this film saying
uh you know it's not really a sequel
it's not it's kind of a its own thing
it's not really a reboot you know like
they keep having these
they won't just define what this is but
i think in i think without saying it
it's still a sequel just maybe not like
all about being a direct part two to
part one but you have the returning
characters here and you have jai
courtney as boomerang plucked straight
out of the first one
and i think killing him off because he
was one of the main characters here
shows you that anyone can die and i
think that's such a great thing to it it
also sets up the
the bruthlessness of amanda waller
like
yeah like we were you were just talking
about with uh savon michael rooker
running away fleeing cowardly into them
i don't even say cowardly i think his
emotions were well justified
he panicked so my point with that is
that when he runs out into the water and
it's like there's nothing he can do he
clearly can't win this fight and then
amanda waller still blows his head like
what's he going to do swim
out of there like what can you do
possibly
swashbuckle across the beach but then
showing that like there's there's
limited chance for survival for these
guys this is gonna be a really hard
mission they can't and anyone could die
here and if you choose not to go through
with it you will die so i thought what
this movie really succeeded at was
creating that tension throughout because
granted a lot of people our main
characters are not dying throughout most
of this movie but by the end you get a
few more deaths yeah um and so i do that
you do get hit with that feeling of man
bloodsport could the only one i didn't
okay if i'm gonna be totally honest the
only one who i never thought for a
second would die is harley quinn like i
never thought harley quinn would die but
i thought everyone else
had a chance of dying here and i think
that's such a difficult thing to do for
a comic book movie and they they pulled
that off really well yeah absolutely and
i mean you know they they don't yeah
undersell the consequences and it's like
this time you know it's like even when
amanda waller is about to actually blow
the bonds then people have to step in
it's like they really thought about how
these situations would play out and they
also scaled the scope of the team to the
situation at hand and so it does feel
like the stakes are super tangible and
the film just does a good job of putting
you at times in their shoes and showing
how intense the mayhem is so like yeah
it feels dangerous and it feels
convincingly yeah like anybody could go
and i think that's also too i mean
that's very conscious use of casting
again but even so like as brief as the
prologue is and i yeah i can get why
anybody would be like i want to see more
of these characters
it is striking it leaves a big
impression and it doesn't uh it's yeah
it's a prologue tonally that kind of
does what the rest of the movie will do
in a much more drawn out sense you know
because yeah like
most people don't make it through this
movie you know
all right so i've seen so i i previewed
the super chats here really quick and i
i hate that feeling when we start
talking about something when someone has
contributed to money our way so let's go
over some of the super chats here uh
really fast john can you pull it off for
us buddy yep yep yep do your thing ready
uh sebastian was probably my favorite
who's your guys's favorite in the
comments in his live stream tell us who
your favorite was here
um yeah i thought
really
that's about i'll say this sebastian was
the one character where the whole time
i'm like
please don't do that animal death thing
please don't please don't please not him
please not him you know and they kill
off so many birds in this film that was
like there's a good chance this rat
could die yeah yeah
yeah don't get attached to anyone living
a human being or animal or otherwise
miles dorsey thank you so much dude can
you can you guys see it yeah okay so
miles dorsey right here at the bottom
all right uh the rescue flag
scene was my favorite the rescue flags
oh so yeah where they go too oh yeah
where are they
just decimate the freedom fighters i
love that shot when a peacemaker just
walks past that one guy laying down and
yeah it's so clinical and the sound
effects totally help sell that too i
think that's a great scene for
peacemaker because john cena like like
what i talked about in my non-spoiler
talk is that this was the first time i
ever really bought john cena as a like
when he had his more dramatic moments in
the finale of this movie i really
believed him and
that never happens to me for john cena i
even rewatched the end of f9 the other
day and i was like man that scene anyway
well if you haven't seen f9 i'm gonna
ruin it but um anywho uh yeah but that
scene showcases you for the first time
like oh this peacemaker is not a joke
he's a real badass he's really up there
he's not really committed yeah he says
he and he's really good at it yeah yeah
absolutely
because you do it does kind of set you
up that blood sport will be the ultimate
badass and peacemaker might be a bit of
a joke
and then in that scene you do see that
oh no there is a there is an equivalency
to the two of them in terms of skill set
yeah yeah and i mean it's an interesting
scene because like i feel like this
scene is a good example of something
that i appreciate about the movie is
that it's a it's a choice of a sequence
and it's a choice of a story beat and i
get why this scene is so divisive again
because of kind of like one of the few
gripes i have is sort of like
ultimately the freedom fighter story
overall doesn't feel as plugged in and
fleshy careless yeah and and the way
alice at the end is like these because
of those people we were able to have
democracy i'm like you you guys stormed
the government too like you know and
then when they showed up in the storm to
go i didn't care i think what you're
getting at is how they don't um
there's
it's a really funny reveal and it's a
really funny joke but there doesn't seem
to be much repercussion from what they
did yeah and it's and because they're
taking a situation for the story that is
a very real world kind of situation like
you know there are tons of uh uh you
know dictatorships and coups around the
world you know i feel like
it is a choice again to make that really
dark joke of like oh man we thought we
were rescuing you yeah um so it's one i
appreciate because of how divisive it
has the potential to be because it is a
distinct and confident choice and you
are you know just kind of free to agree
or not yeah
but i thought yeah especially
that was very funny in a very very dark
way
smooth king 2000 uh thank you buddy you
guys rock in the movie rocks
i was really glad to get my video out um
one of the first
i bet and then i was also met with that
anytime i put an opinion out there i'm
also met with the worry of what if i'm
like in the minority yeah because i
haven't heard anybody else
the scary part of seeing a movie with no
reviews out like you got to be honest
it's like when we did black widows like
gotta be honest but we'll see yeah uh
john you want to read this one yeah josh
wren thanks you so much i loved the film
so much i really felt that peacemaker's
change of character was great how did
you feel thank you
uh yeah i mean that is you know again
you do get attached to these characters
even though peacemaker is not the most
lovable of them but even you know over
the course of the film you see him even
start to bond with ratcatcher a little
bit and yeah it's a great example of
amanda waller's ruthlessness and the
ruthlessness of shadowy operations like
this in general is yeah he's again just
dedicated to ultimately this one
specific version of a liberty ideology
and and yeah it's very sinister when
he's like you know i will do anything to
make sure that this information doesn't
get out and then yeah it brings out the
like true moral quandary of the movie
and so i thought as a character choice
you know it he sold it really well and
also it made the movie that much
stronger because then it becomes about
something you know
it adds another element again so i can
understand if you maybe are overwhelmed
at that point but for me it was like oh
damn there's more to every piece of the
plan and puzzle than met the eye you
know i'd agree with that i think that
with that peacemaker turn i personally
was bummed out by it some people might
not be surprised by the turn i love that
it's committed to the character i love
how the scene became about a battle of
philosophy between rick flagg and
peacemaker in that moment and to be
perfectly frank it's like as much as i
view rick flagmore as the good guy than
peacemaker overall even prior to that
scene like you brought up him bonnie
with ratcatcher that moment at the bar
like i think that bar moment the first
time i watched that scene the very first
time i thought
is this really necessary to be in this
movie i feel like it might be messing
with the pace but then as the movie
progressed i realized that that scene is
so important to making you care yeah
because you do get the sense of
camaraderie with them becoming a team
that scene in the bar in the first
suicide squad movie which maybe in the
air cut there is more of like the
richness to that but like i feel like
that bar scene there in the first
suicide squad movie they did it properly
here and yeah him this peacemaker saying
get a drink for the rat i thought makes
you go oh this guy has a heart this
guy's good and i never thought i
actually personally don't think
peacemaker was a bad guy
necessarily like well like i i don't
agree with him and what he did was bad
it's that thing it's kind of it's i get
his argument and for now and when our
goals no longer align then you know
we we have no consideration for each
other any longer well you know that
thing when people say
um
you know i think when people say like
he's a good villain because i understand
his motives and i understand like he
thinks of himself as the good guy
this
if if you are to view him as a villain
then i think he is one of the better
arguments for
that philosophy of
you actually told like no that's his
character of course
of course he's going to do this he
really thinks he's doing something good
right now he thinks he's doing the right
thing and then the scene between um uh
john cena and and rick flagg i didn't
want any one of them to die so it was it
was like oh that was tough to watch and
and you you do kind of suspect that
flag's probably going to be the one to
take the hit which was a bummer i really
cared about him that was my most
heartbreaking death i think absolutely
um
gene
gene
that's our wolverine impression
um
yeah no the rick flag death was the what
that was that that was the homer i'm
like [ __ ] i hate it i didn't hate him
but i like this guy i didn't care about
him i own the first one i like him so
much now what a bummer and he was really
trying to do the good thing
and it's moments like that that also
when he shares that one little glance
with harley why i'm like i think this is
at least in the same world as the last
movie
yeah as much as they've tried to
distance it like they honor that and
sell it
uh jean jeter august 7th my favorite day
every year and probably will stay that
way have a good live spoiler soon oh
well thank you for the support buddy oh
buddy marina john read this in your best
friend accent love from sydney australia
that's uh that's a great old uh aussie
accent there thank you so much marina
and nash
one of our patrons
uh who is thank you who is amanda gonna
kill in the third movie
oh [ __ ] i don't know anybody left it
would be cool if they managed to take
those survived from the first suicide
squad movie and then once a year and
then mash them and then make it the
redemption for everything yeah this is
this ultimate suicide squad yeah dude
oh and then any other like uh get any
other like good dc eu villain
performances that haven't been included
yet yeah that would be amazing
i mean it does make me wonder because
this movie does feel like a sequel in
the way like an anthology
story is a sequel you know if you have
some of the same characters so i feel
like you could do a
i feel like you could do a lot without
having to like directly branch out of
this movie the next time around well i
feel like i'm surprised that she didn't
execute any of her actual uh
her style her style
over the head yeah
yeah i was a little surprised by that
all right let's put this away for now
uh what a joke was a great line what do
you think about that what'd you think
about king shark johnny oh i really
enjoyed king shark and especially uh you
know getting to enjoy i think the poetic
you know sort of beats with him played a
little more smoothly to me the second
time around and i was really able to
kind of uh really follow the tone and i
appreciated the opportunity he took with
that character because yeah there's
funny dialogue because of how sort of
monosyllabic he is but you also get
these great little
just emotional moments of you know when
they're cruising through the city and
he's sort of watching just regular human
life or when he's sitting in the truck
and he's really bummed yeah or he's
having the moment he's learning about
friendship throughout the movie
you know and uh yeah i i ultimately
really appreciated him and also the way
they handled his sort of
somewhat invincibility because
you know it's it's interesting to note
like the limitations he has being kind
of a big lumbering character while also
you know having the obvious advantage of
like the shark teeth and everything but
i thought they they scaled him well as
well and made him you know an actual
part of the team that you know felt
essential while still oddball hey we got
we got costly wonder in the chat what's
going on buddy cosmic showing his love
for dc today
and yes i mean we did see the
post-credits scene at the very end uh
showcasing peacemaker uh that he's still
alive which somehow survived that which
i was like
when he died in the movie or at least
when you think he's dead i was going
oh so the peacemaker show must be a
prequel yeah exactly
which because i didn't think he would he
would get killed at all i didn't suspect
that whatsoever yeah which is the main
reason why i was like flag is probably
gonna die because there's a peacemaker
show coming up
um
but then yeah for them to live at the
end i was kind of surprised by how
amanda waller let those staff members
live
yeah
they're still like actively on her
payroll and this is just like a shitty
assignment for them
but also it seems like a very important
assignment for them because it's like
saving the [ __ ] world so
yeah
i think it's it's probably
i would imagine that these characters
were probably culled because of their
own
moral dubiousness in other regards so
maybe there's something you know that we
don't know about about how their
relationship works but but in terms of
what the movie gives you it is quite
surprising that any of that staff is
still around and it's just maybe at this
point they just know way too much or
something uh for the past few days i've
just been saying i'm numb around the
house i can't stop saying that not num
num i love that scene when uh king shark
is off on his own at the at the um
yodenheim castle or whatever and then he
sees that aquarium of fish and his
bonding with them and and to me that's
such a great tone poem moment such a
great visual illustration of this guy
really is just wants friends and he's
really just lonely and he needs to learn
about fun yeah i love that i thought
they struck a great balance with him in
terms of being like
he's kind of like if you're going to
compare a guardian to the galaxy to this
he is kind of like the groot of the
group
and he is sort of uh
like the more vicious violent version of
him but i thought they did such an
amazing job at really having you find
him
really sweet and endeared to him and
then thinking he's so awesome when he's
shredding people too yeah yeah yeah he
has one of the best gore gags in the
entire movie and i was i was it's when
you're like totally expecting a head
chomp and he just rips that guy in half
like so satisfying
are you excited for the peacemaker
series
i'm curious about it it's funny i i feel
like it it will i mean if james gunn has
been involved with it heavily then it
will have a similar sort of a
sensibility to this but i'm curious to
see if it's just centered around him and
he's the main sort of meta-powered
person uh what that would play like
because i think part of the charm of a
character like that especially in a
movie like this is that it is an
ensemble and he isn't the lion's share
of screen time
so i'm i'm
again it'll depend on how much more his
acting credibility can sell being the
centerpiece of an entire you know show
but
generally speaking it's got me
optimistic for it and happy to see that
character return and it makes me uh it
sounds like a fun challenge to be like
okay i'm gonna have to root for this guy
next time and stranger things have
happened so yeah show me that
i also was kind of taken aback by
how much i
sympathized for sorrow
that's the the they gave even staro has
a point of view and has an
understandable you know motivation by
the end of it you know yeah like i was
happy among the stars and then you guys
kidnapped me so you know what you're
having to take this city i mean hey
turjo student we are reading live
comments that's what's determining all
these questions and
everything i've been bringing up and
changing the subject around usually
there's a good embassy there's stacks of
people saying similar things so i'm just
kind of gathering bits and pieces of
information little by little and then
driving the conversation from there so
yeah i am going off with a live stream
chat um it just can look like favorites
you know if i'm
shouting out one person who mentioned
this but then there's also five other
people while you speak the actual
questions i'll just read every name i
can see
i mean with starro it wasn't starro's
fault for being in that
position at all and it's like this this
being was yes
i just said no oh i just said no it
didn't well
uh i think sorrow was uh
this character who
started like it was [ __ ] up what sarah
was doing at the end but you're like but
they've been torturing this guy for like
how long now like like several decades
at this point and sorrow's just doing
what star wars does and they just
captured him and they were even found
even captured in the astronauts and like
showing it was kind of like a little
prize that they got yeah and then all
they do is do that but you know
obviously murdering all those innocent
people not but i thought that was an and
a detail to this to this monster this
kaiju-like character that i just wasn't
anticipating at all with this film and
that's what i mean by adding another
layer to it i think what james gunn did
really well here
uh with people asking about the
direction is that a lot of the
maybe there's not a heavy amount of
scenes that are just like
all about the drama and the nuance there
but i think that's really well spread
out throughout this whole thing it's
like you introduce the joke unlike a
funny manner with bloodsport uh and he's
scared of rats like
and it's kind of just like a silly thing
and by the way i think idris elba very
very like deserves to be more
appreciated for his work absolutely
brilliant in this film hilarious and i
love how he just keeps getting like
injured
it does he has like that indiana jones
quality to me where he's not just like
like that's a bit oh one sec one sec
we got it that's like a big difference i
think between watching deadshot and
bloodsport because obviously people will
compare
the two of them for the type of
assassins they are they're both black
leading characters and they will have it
in a situation with wanting to take care
of their daughter right i still think
the portrayals of them
are entirely different portrayals and
they have very different personalities
and i much rather prefer the
interpretation that we got a blood sport
over the dead shot because like blizzard
is just constantly bitching and
complaining it's always like [ __ ]
every second of the movie and just
having a rough time and he keeps getting
hurt and
so
i root for the guy because when he's
having those fight scenes it's not
pretty it it looks like he's sometimes
having a struggle i love like the
struggle in a fight like when he has
that shot when he goes up to starro
loading the gun all these and then
jurgen klopp
and they all start running away before
he's done shooting it just that and then
when the star and the people who are
like a zombie horde of star of
characters coming after him and he's
going through all his different weapons
it's a tough battle it's a fight and
when he put out you feel that
exasperation exactly
but you can also feel
exactly feeling that exasperation from
him feeling the lethargic nature of him
coming on
um but you also know that he's there's a
softy inside of this guy you know he's
scared of the rats he really cares about
rat hatcher too oh by the way the moment
with rat catcher too when she's doing
the light thing and then she puts her
arm over him oh what a beautiful bumper
protecting him hey paul have you
spoilers in the chat what's up buddy hey
what's up great to have you here
for the moment you will be here i know
how you other youtubers are you pop in
here for like a minute
hey just to steal this shot audience
over to your video guys go subscribe to
heavy spoilers he's got a wonderful
ending explaining a wonderful
post-credits scene breakdown and such
no that's the thing that's the thing i
think about the deadshot and bloodsport
argument is they solve it with that
whole thing about like his his backstory
with peacemakers the same as mine it's
like you can imagine blood dead shots
backstories like yeah his father trained
him since he was a kid should be like
the most ruthless assassin anything in
his hands as a weapon it is one of those
questions though of
of uh
they say he shot superman put him in the
icu is superman still in the icu and
that's why he doesn't show up at the
star situation
maybe he just did that
like a month ago and they've just been
asking all month
they established that as much as this
suicide squad is its own thing superman
still around here yeah and i think he
would have been able to get there in the
amount of time that unfolded on the
screen at least i know there's been some
controversy regarding the harley quinn
portrayal which we will get to in a
second but let's kick it off right here
with uh we got a few more super chats
that came in
uh
brandon hobbs
you guys are saving me for my depression
i love you keep being friends
we're trying we're hanging on a little
bit
each week by week no matter what happens
we try
for the sake of public display some
weeks are up some weeks are down but
they're always
they're always us uh smooth king 2000
also i was shocked that they killed
captain boomerang and rick flag two
original members from the last movie
i think if you pay close enough to the
trailers it was pretty obvious boomerang
who's gonna die yeah he's only in this
like couple shots
and you know what even though he's in it
less like i love jai courtney's
portrayal of him in the first one i
didn't love him but i liked him a lot uh
healy's got to do some cool [ __ ] this
time around versus
versus the last you didn't do anything
yeah
yeah
he's in it way more and he gets to have
more lines and stuff because because of
the time he's in it but he's gonna do
anything cool in that movie yeah um at
least here he gets to actually use his
boomerang and slice some guys up you
know yeah exactly you guys really gets
to be a badass and i loved his little
feature in the main credits with just
the arms sticking up out of the out of
the sand and i feel like it's another
great way of he's such a fun and
confident character so reintroducing us
you know to a new team with a couple
familiar characters it's like you know
returning to school after a summer and
it's like oh i only know you two so like
i'm kind of gravitated towards you guys
like he's a perfect character for that
and it also sets you up for that feeling
of loss with the guy yeah
mateo diavino sounds like a super
italian man over here
i love the movie and a highlight for me
is king shark i hope we get more
appearances from him in the future but
my biggest complaint is that he never
said king shark is a shock
i wish he did say that that is one of
his main quotes that i'm surprised he
didn't bummer
it's in a deleted scene somewhere i do
i really love the handling of him he's
about to eat rat catcher
i'm surprised didn't just immediately
chomp considering everything else we've
seen in the movie he's about to eat rat
catcher very very quiet about it and the
first guy you see him swallow you see
him in the background
it's just like this little son of my
cute little pulling over like a child
oh amazing sylvester stallone good for
you wasn't the guy who is the one who's
like that's a kaiju and the one who
keeps standing up against amanda waller
or wondering of like will you really
kill
bloodsports kid i think he's the one who
actually um did the mocap for king shark
in the movie comedian steve agee who i
think is another yeah he's another james
gunn sort of regular i think
uh let's i hope kings it would be cool
to see king shark and killer croc
meet each other yeah
if the kill killer croc make it through
the last movie it could happen yeah yeah
it'll be great i don't know if he's in
the air oh he's so good
bring him back
redemption let's see here
king let's see here i'm looking at the
chat
sat at test with either polka dot man or
rick flag
i think rick flack had the more tragic
death
yeah in the in the story itself i think
overall he probably got to lead a better
life
um
taj jinko was asking that question
however
uh polka dot man i obviously had the
more tragic life overall but he gets to
have an arc there and i think that's
that's what i mean it's like there's
there are these nuances here that are
not sometimes so in your face
but he goes from a guy who
like
that
the way they introduce their character
journeys can be so funny because like i
said with indus elba with rat catcher uh
with the rat how they make that funny
and then by the end he's like overcoming
the fear petting his rad because so much
of his trauma is based off when he was
tortured with rats and he's overcoming
it in that moment you know
part of that trauma is probably why he
ended up down the life he did right so i
think that's a really cool little
journey to put him on and then with
polka dot man like the that first one of
his early lines of
like it's easier if i can just imagine
they're my mom like it's just an
unexpected line it just sounds like a
joke yeah and then you find out oh this
is his backstory here yeah this is a
real thing that we're gonna deal with
and i love that james gunn committed to
the visual illustration of hopping into
his perspective of showing no he really
sees everyone as his mom and even when
bloodsports like you see that
that's your mom yeah then it's like it's
giant
mom but the guy is so depressed and
feels so much shame about himself and in
the in the end of it when he's like i'm
a superhero he finally got to feel love
for himself and proud of himself when
the whole time he's feeling shamed
towards himself and so i think that is
he he at least gets to die in his life
on a high note yeah zenith of yeah
exactly and um as predictable as it was
when he said i'm a superhero i was like
oh he's gonna die like a second he said
i'm like oh [ __ ] he's gonna die right
now yeah and then they do this they do
the far the
profile shot where he turns something
once more you're like oh that's death
shot right there yeah that's the
shot crush
you know that's the shot where he's
gonna die what's gonna fall on him
debris or a starling um
but uh i i think in the movie itself
it's like
rick flagg died when he was trying to do
just the right thing he has the moral
debt yes the moral death versus like the
the emotional death you know and that's
why they both stand out so much as yeah
for polka dot man for abner you're just
so
you know overjoyed with him just for
yeah like finally you you feel a moment
of peace and confidence whereas yeah
rick flag is like you just made the hero
choice and you're you're gonna pay the
worst price for
trying to be the best person on this
team you know we see like you got t in
the chat who's saying pokemon's death is
an example of what i don't like about
guns directing style sacrificing power
moments for a jump gag
so i didn't really i didn't get that
impression though
i i i felt everything we just said
it felt within the spirit of the movie
and i mean it's like exactly it could
have gone either way but
like i don't know i i do understand that
because there's a gag there you know it
they're you know that might offset the
emotional resonance of any part of that
for you but but yeah i don't feel
like it cheapened it for for me you see
tyler in the chat is saying like i i
literally didn't see pokemon's pokemon
pokemon pokemon polka dot man's death
coming and there were like olivia didn't
see it coming i was sitting next to her
and and then she like jumped at it and i
was like so surprised by that
but weasel's death at the beginning
i loved that well and even those little
details of like you didn't check to make
sure he could swim you know you didn't
check to make sure bloodsport had a
phobia of something and that whole thing
about like why would i disclose my
vulnerabilities see i feel like he james
going to create this cool tone and world
within the dc universe already like just
task force x the the employees placing
bets on who's gonna who's gonna die now
like this never goes well you know who's
gonna die next i and and showing that
the suicide squad clearly this is a
thing they keep trying and it gets just
not working because you have a bunch of
p you know it's that thing of like you
have a bunch of big personalities with
big powers all of whom you know probably
have some kind of megalomania complex
and so like those aren't the people best
suited for team and tactics so like this
is always gonna go pear-shaped in some
way shape or form and and yeah i feel
like that's part of the sort of rye
charm of the world
i left right when the movie ended and
then i came back for the peace crit
peacemaker post-credits scene was there
any scene after that no can't think of
anything too bad
the whole time is permanently dead yeah
he's just permanently dead
in fact they did a marvel at the end
that's what i saw is they they had a
title card that said weasel
will not return because he's dead
yeah weasel is the bomb all right
and that's the other thing is like wreak
havoc in in that city yeah and it's such
a gross off-putting design and i feel
like you know in another movie it might
not have been able to be that way and
that's another sort of like james gunn
sort of troma thing is like weasel does
look disgusting
i do want to touch on thinker uh peter
capaldi in a second we got a few more
super chats here that i do not want to
ignore because you guys thank you guys
for supporting us here
really means a lot thank you
um let's see here where are we at
uh ha ha
[Music]
right here another one
thank you meteo diovino i don't know if
you saw my super chat but are you as
disappointed as i am that king shark
never said king shark is a shark i don't
know if i'm as disappointed as you yeah
but i did want him to say that that's
for sure i did at least want to hear him
say it once
childlike being
you know
a lot of people seem really bummed by
the fact that like this this is a big
takeaway for them the rick flag
and uh
boomerang died yeah like i i felt it
when boomerang died and rick flag
uh but it seems to be like the most
reoccurring comment so far since we've
been live which is fascinating child
like being they just murdered my boy
rick flag and captain boomerang but i
thought it would have been cool to see a
cameo from one or two of the jail crew
to help the suicide squad with starro i
think that would have undercut it a
little bit i mean it would have been
cool yes but not as strong i would say
in terms of the story they're telling
because one thing i really liked about
the ending of
the mission because they complete the
mission and not at one point
this is what i mean by james gunn
subtlety with nuances from time to time
that you don't realize he's building to
like i did not think he was building to
them doing anything heroic the entire
movie
i really didn't think that other than a
like amanda waller says
i i you have leadership potential or
something like that bloodsport at the
top
but
we don't
spend the whole movie going you're gonna
be a leader you're gonna be a leader we
don't keep pointing that out
and
so in the end of it they complete their
mission they do their job they don't
have to deal with sorrow they don't have
to do any of that none of that is a
requirement on their end
but they all choose to do the right
thing and help out when they realize
they're probably the only ones here who
can yeah and it needs to happen now so
that's why i think it's better that the
jail doesn't show up and or whatever
like that um so
uh but i think in terms of like really
showing that no they they did grow as
characters because
this is not a necessity yeah and they
were willing to have their heads
exploded for that yeah you know like i
didn't know how they would get out of
that
yeah
and then bam
and like what how how are they gonna
who's she gonna start blowing one of
their heads up like how did they get out
of here exactly and then i i actually
didn't i didn't anticipate that one of
them would knock her out yeah but
they're but see they're they're building
that up too you know what i mean they're
building up task force x
have uh going against
uh not task versus um is that what you
call them you wouldn't call them the
people who work with amanda waller yeah
what's her bureau called forgetting the
name of the bureau or offhand anyway you
know the office of suicide squad affairs
either building that up that they would
do that yet you don't see it coming in
that moment yeah yeah no it's a perfect
yeah because you're waiting and now jaby
coware here right hey hey everyone's
stopping by youtubers so stop boston
crossover event of the summer yeah yeah
and that's a great but that's another
great i think turn and that's something
that again just sort of keeps on playing
of on that theme of the choice of you
know like what lengths are you willing
to go to and what at what point do you
not see the sort of mutual destruction
in in action you know
and so yeah i really like that turn for
her staff i completely agree with you
john
all right
jaby
jabby raids yeah everyone's just coming
jabbing jabby raid brandon steele love
you guys and love the movie thank you
braden steele thank you brayden i really
appreciate that buddy braden
kiefer
all right hey we're gonna talk about
harley now oh hey
kiefer grundmann brady i feel like they
uh we were all reminded wait to the
parties here sorry
no hey the more the merrier man i'm
happy to see everybody i feel like we
were all reminded of how much a nutcase
harley is lol her fight scene after
being tortured was incredible
yeah
i i i really enjoyed uh her
that fight in particular because of all
the you know visual flourishes and the
really cool like sideways tracking shot
and the acrobatics and stuff but also i
i really appreciated the javelin
storyline
i think what this hardly said some
people have been very back and forth on
the harley take i've seen it on social
media
um
i haven't really dived too deep into
there are people who don't like the way
she was written in this film especially
with the whole like i'm a princess
and when she's looking at herself after
being kidnapped and then swooning over
the guy
and to me it didn't bother me because i
was like
yeah i think harley has grown and she
does shoot the guy in the end you know
and yeah she was going down the path of
being manipulated and all that
and as larger than life as this is as
fantastical as the world of dc is and
this movie is no is definitely an
inclusion in that
um i also think it's perfectly human for
someone who has been working on
something to keep going back to the same
mistake and then catching themselves
midway through it yeah that's that's how
i ultimately read it and you know i'm
i'm gonna you know wait to hear some
more opinions on it but the way i took
it is that yeah the joke comes around
finally of like i promised myself that
if i saw any red flags and i feel like
every step of the way from being pulled
out of the hole to that moment is just a
million red flags and it goes to show
like yeah like you know she's she's been
she's like newly uh emancipated from
this horrific relationship with the
joker that altered her life her
psychological state her physical ability
and everything else that yeah i mean it
seemed like
this guy doesn't seem
half as abusive as the joker and so like
having that history yeah i could see you
know how
several misfla red flags might be missed
and a character who you know in the
commentary is like
heavily used to abuse and and
manipulation from you know a significant
other it played as that as sort of like
this is a sign of growth and yeah
you know ideally she would have caught
the red flag immediately
but uh you know yeah it's also a
selfless turn when she's like
you know i've been through a lot but
little kids you know like you can't kill
little kids well yeah i mean it's like
harley's not
a good
he's not a hero she's not
harley's not a hero she's like literally
she draws the line at kids yeah but
everything else she was fine with it
yeah yeah like take people off to your
murder castle whatever but the children
and she could have the money the power
have love
you know like
the birdies everything but the kids yeah
yeah yeah and i love the speech that she
gives that to me is this interesting way
of showing her arc from the first
suicide squad movie including birds of
prey and then here of she was still able
to catch herself and go
no i can't you know but i love the
sadistic nature of how she just had sex
with this guy yeah and then killed him
like i love his sadistic nature
absolutely and i thought the fight scene
was incredible i i uh what i i love this
scene where she's getting tortured it's
pretty brutal i love it and i'm like
yeah [ __ ] i'm not like that about it
but it makes you think of kind of like
an 80s action movie like lethal weapon
or something when mel's tied up and like
how she's getting beat up and you really
buy into like oh man she's she's screwed
right here she's really messed up
and what i thought
i did i didn't quite notice it until i
didn't notice what was different about
her fight scene here other than like
choreography and all that
that really stood out to me versus
take the
police
uh the police station scene in birds of
prey
was
here in this fight she might have her
like little
devilish smiles from time to time but
for the most part and the most part in
that fight she's really quiet she's like
an action hero yeah like an action
fighter here with a slight little
twinkle in her in her eye you know like
so she's still enjoying it but i thought
that's what made her even cooler was
kind of like the silent lethal killer
and how she's
how it's not until the very end of the
fight where she's letting it all out and
then screaming that famous the popular
shot of
the wheel with the guns and the flowers
and the birds
like she's coming to life here yeah and
then when she's outside i love the touch
of how when she's looking for a cab if
you pay attention to the background the
birds are still going off inside in the
back like you have to look for it but
you can still see all the birds and
stuff in the background yeah but she's
still pretty quiet the whole time and i
thought
compared to the other movies i thought
there was so much more going under going
on underneath
the surface for margot robbie here
uh versus just her having to say it or
do comedy you know like i thought it was
cool that you got to have some quiet
time with her visceral quiet time it was
quiet but you know moments where she's
not just making jokes or blabbing the
whole time you know yeah where you just
i mean yeah it's just yells if anything
yeah and uh and aj sumano in the chat's
pointing out that margot robbie did the
escape herself and james gunn says he
wished he shot it better so as to see
her face i was wondering about that
because it looks really convincing like
with the keys
yeah i mean i don't i don't know if you
think she got it into one tick i mean
there's an insert on the key going into
the lock but i'm saying i i i would
believe that she did like the acrobatic
like you know flip upward and all that
core strength and you know contortion or
whatever
uh
yeah i i really enjoyed that and and
some i know there's been some back and
forth too on just how that plot line
factors in with the suicide squad of
like ah this feels like a side quest and
like you know by the time they get there
to rescue her she's already rescued
herself uh but that to me was another
example of something that added into
like this movie to me really feels like
when you read a graphic novel and you
know you can tell you know you have
separate issues mixed in together it
added to that for me but it also i think
added to the overall sense of like
this is like uh
you know i i flashed back to guardians
of the galaxy because you see the team
and then peter sierra finishes like
they're a bunch of [ __ ] and uh you
know it's like it's a similar vibe here
but not undercutting them so much that
they you know aren't an effective team
when it needs to be it's like it it it
shows something about like their uh uh
you know approach
in how it sort of goes sideways and they
don't even really need to be there but
also they're still really capable and
they had a good plan you know yeah so it
speaks yeah to their like weird
mismatched disorganization but also
without undercutting their yeah just
effective qualities
uh let's talk about the thinker really
quick okay so with the thinker peter
capaldi
uh
i think peter capaldi did an excellent
job in the role i did and i actually
really did enjoy watching him there i
really did enjoy watching him
um
and i actually didn't have this
criticism until the second time i
watched the movie
uh is that
like i think i i personally think video
quality is like an excellent job and in
terms of what the character like what is
the thinker's actual name like gaius
grieves gaius grieves okay
so
i think in portraying gaius grieves
that's he's excellent i think in
portraying the thinker he's not really
utilized like you said and it's like
okay
the thinker this really big
comic book villain
has this genius level capability
he was one of the main villains like he
had one i think of season four of the
flash where he was the primary villain
and the way they wrote him in there
i was there as an audience member going
how the hell like as the season
progressed i'm like how do you beat this
guy that's impossible there's no way you
can beat him you know i would watch the
thinker there
doing that and then here there's not
much thinker going on
they said and it's like okay someone
might say well you're just saying that
because of the comic material or
watching the flash or whatever i'm like
okay let's let's remove that
the movie sets you up for that that
movie when they introduce him says
what's with all the he's got all these
bolts in his head
and they're saying
you know like what does that do makes
you really smart yeah it makes me smart
and and
as much as like you
you know he's the main scientist
experimenting on starro you don't really
get to explore
the genius side of him or really get to
get a like what made what's with all the
bolts like what makes him still what
makes him super genius who is this yeah
really and what is the breadth of his
ability not that we know all his power
not that we like need to know everything
about him just you got to do with a
bunch of bolts in his head yeah you're
setting him up for that and i i wish
there was just like a couple of scenes
or some exchange of
dialogue or whatever that at least
allows you to
really see that i thought we were going
to see that when he got captured
like when uh
when they're running out of there and
he's saying like i'm working like when
he's admiring rat catchers ability is
like i've been working on something like
that myself they have the rats up your
[ __ ] joke and um yeah stuff like that
so i thought in that scene we're gonna
start hearing some of it but we never
really got that um
[Music]
you know what you know what i'm getting
it yeah end of end we never got
fully realized and it is a situation you
know with star in scope that is pretty
big and and could have maybe opened the
door for yeah broader he does play sort
of as just mad scientist
yeah you know gaius grieves mad
scientist yes exactly um yeah and yeah i
absolutely like i don't have as much
experience with that character
intimately so i wasn't as bothered by it
but also yeah i mean i
looking back on it now i'm like it would
have been cool to see more from him
and see a more special character because
he just kind of looks cool and is a
great performance but in terms of
playing evil scientists he was great
absolutely yeah great performance i
don't think it was really like a great
version of the thinker but in terms of
evil scientists it was it was great
really effectively utilized there and uh
quickly happy birthday jean g peter
happy birthday to you
ah let's see here hey lace the wood 96
you just got the theater what'd you
think about the movie hey
oh and and ragu
uh see theramon uh i noticed that uh the
second in the credits the that that uh
dee bradley baker was sebastian the rest
dee bradley baker is like the number one
voice actor isn't it he is
he's got his own show he's in everything
he's got a whole show where's every
character he's got every other show and
his own show where he's also all the
voices
really do appreciate everyone who's
contributed here to the super chats too
we also have streamlabs open as well
there's a pinned uh
chat comment if you are interested there
or in the description box but now it's
been fun talking about we've there's
still more to unpack i believe absolute
vodka uh cam k
wait no no no no i i'm wrong i'm wrong
i'm wrong
oh oh there's a few more okay i'm bad i
messed up here okay we we did kiefer
last time i think it's mike t
yes mike t can you see that yeah mike t
54 thank you
buddy if there is a third suicide squad
i hope they can get deadshot back i feel
like he was a standout of the last film
and deserves another go i was shocked at
boomerang in flagstaff and see again
another comment about it this is the
most recurring thing here
uh yeah i mean i i think it would kind
of be fun to see
a will smith and uh idris elba
i mean that would be awesome for casting
and just for back and forth of the
characters i just watched a movie
you have to started
suicide squad they would be unstoppable
together
this is the two best marksman ever
that would be amazing
yeah i do think will smith
you see that's the difference here's i
still thought will smith was will smith
yeah yeah absolutely he's just gruff
wilson is his corrupter will smith right
yeah like different shapes
but idris elba to me was a real
character yeah yeah i know what i mean
yeah like we've seen idris elba play
tough guy and i think it's really great
like jeff snyder actually pointed this
out of how he is not someone there's
elba's constantly these big ten pull
movies but is is not in any good ones
until he finally gets a role here that's
substantial and really gets a chance to
showcase so don't overlook the guy but
anyway
um yeah deadshot uh and him would be
great together but i would still i'd
like to see that i think that'd be a fun
for a third film i do think it'd be fun
to mix and match some of the cast yeah
absolutely and i mean you know incapable
hands i think any of these possibilities
would be fun you know if james gunn
wants to do more and decides to bring
further you know back characters in do
it yeah
we will watch eric boss's easter egg
breakdown it's a movie breakdown we'll
probably put that up tomorrow morning so
keep a look out for that let's figure
we'll do our spoiler talk first
um not we're not rushing to get it up
right now but it's russian yes
this is a little side note yeah yeah
like that those are always like uh
obviously not as intense of an edit as
the actual new rockstars does but for us
we're like
if there's one of the marvel shows that
that's usually like a quick it's it's
it's quite a bit of more work than you
might think it is i'll say that all
right it's not gonna he's not gonna
do it his fingers are catching fire
um
copyright claim your brother is live on
his channel jabby live please rate him
gregory i'm not gonna be a dick let him
be a dick and come here i'll rate
him dick i'll go i'll go on the floor
and raid your brother's ass
mike t-54
uh thank you again buddy if there is a
third suicide squad movie who will be
the five-person team you'd want them to
focus on of the survivors of one and two
ooh
what a way to narrow it down
all of that
our camera is uh canon and it cuts every
30 minutes yes
everybody who's subscribed everyone from
the suicide squad
shot
yeah
yeah
well because yeah we already got rat
catching catcher harley and and uh
bloodsport do we count weasel are we
gonna count weasel do we want weasel no
i could sacrifice weasel peacemaker i
think's doing his own thing that's fine
let him you know you know how zack snyde
uh not exactly that shot why am i saying
zack snyder the watchman you know how
the watchman um oh that's why i was
saying zack snyder
no watchmen the graphic novel has the
tail from the tails on the freight what
the hell is that called the tails of the
black freighter yeah yeah so they have
that in there and i think it would be
cool for the next one if you just weave
into like an occasional cut test uh
weasel storyline yeah yeah no he never
joins the team like in like in ice age
movies when they cut to scrat
yeah yeah it's always just like a little
comic strip in the middle yeah i would
be down see we said earlier though that
we need a king shark and a killer croc
so i feel like you know
that that means we're going to have to
sacrifice somebody
we want to that be king shark
i prefer king shark over killer
king sharks oh i thought we wanted them
to meet all right king shark dead
[Music]
yeah what do we want diablo diablo died
yeah but we could we could resurrect him
no not in a comic book universe
lairdo love what you guys do awesome
work oh thanks buddy thank you lairdo
it means a lot i love what you do
in being here today
hey greg and john fannie y'all's in
campia oh great to see you there he's
here in the chat
yeah char campy is in the chat what up
anyways he's submitting a topic do you
feel like king shark should have done
something more significant
i thought he did i've watched a lot of
king shark interpretations
a lot he's sometimes been the main
villain of an episode or two in flash or
more than that he's appeared quite a bit
really humanized him at one point
it's you know many animated stuff
he's he's hilarious in the harley quinn
show
this is about what king shark would do i
like i don't i don't feel like king
shark would have done that much more
it doesn't seem this is i thought he was
perfectly used perfectly he's not going
to be your your leader of the teeth
oh katana though going back to the
previous question would be uh michael
marx says that katana that's that'll be
a good one that's one i would like to
see the potential delivered upon for
sure
braden steele felt bad for starro
was tortured and wanted to float in
space
oh wanna do it's floating
winnie the pooh of course he was bad i
would have been mad sad if
um how do you pronounce that no no no no
no no no no way god i always forget it
nanaway that's how they were not no way
i gotta say do a syllable
not not way the fish eating him scared
me i thought he was gonna die there i
did too
this is what it'll be these
intergalactic jellyfish will be the
sinker what a shitty way to kill him
we just introduce these fish are we
gonna kill him yeah there's nothing to
do with the main plot
yeah
i don't know yeah i thought his his his
purpose was served nicely and he is such
a presence you know yeah
and sylvester stallone was like
perfectly like
it is a strange it's it's strange to me
how gunn has the ability to go
buff action hero limited dialogue come
to my voice booth you'll be perfect for
this guy have fun with this do all the
tapes yeah then you go in here yeah do
an individual groot for every single one
yeah
and i appreciate stallone for being down
for that i feel like he wouldn't do that
for just anybody so james gunn you know
again either must have something on him
or just must be that you know respect
deserving for you know filmmaking proud
look i don't know if you guys are
enjoying the stream but if you are you
can you please hit that like button if
you are um i'm not looking at
views or how many people are here i'm
not doing any of that today so whoever's
just here thank you and um
i am really uh i'm enjoying this we
haven't done a live stream in so long so
this is this is fun
uh cam k just got here is john's hair
lining up with harley quinn's on his
shirt intentional
what a while coincidence if not well
john is it uh i mean i i did these
braids intentionally flash it away uh
the fact that they're not lining up the
fact that they're that they are uh
hers go up here yeah i mean hers are
like yeah but like the fact that they
kind of fall in the same place on the
shirt is
coincidental as are the the colors being
similar for the time yeah it's just kind
of life-having stance well it looks
great
and the ladies love it this is just for
today just for suicide squad nash senate
hey buddy i also thought thinker worked
uh more like a dwight schrute character
actually i actually totally see where
you're coming from i 100 see where
you're going
now i just imagined a rain wilson
version of the thinker these old
beats storeo must reduce baits
someone's gotta make a someone's gonna
meme that someone's gonna you wanna be
he's gonna watch your character that is
to me that is an apt comparison deep
deep fake some thinker moments into
office scenes
oh that's hysterical thank you thank you
for that nash i love that a lot
gene happy birthday again
happy birthday to you humphrey quinn
thank you gene
gene joint
i didn't know who bloodsport was now i
do can't believe we got a movie with no
gender race swapping and it was awesome
i think that's what happens when you
just have a really diverse cast
you know
it's like it is just a very diverse cast
and it doesn't really have any
need to be like check out our diversity
guys raccoon the chat is saying is that
how do you pronounce your name brag hugh
i always get names like yours wrong did
you guys notice palm clementuff because
because he's always in ever he comments
on like pretty much every one of our
videos did you guys notice palm
clementine
teef is as the dancer in the suicide
squad
uh did you i did not uh is that the
guardians of the galaxy easter egg that
everyone's saying that i did not notice
yeah is that the one yeah i didn't
notice it the first time i noticed the
shot and the way the shot was held and i
was like that's somebody and then the
second time i was like oh it's uh it's
mantis you know she's uh on when they go
into the bar and there's that shot of
the dancers like up on the table in
their basement oh that's why she looks
so familiar in the middle
yeah once you described the shot i i saw
it yeah
so you know a little guardians love
there okay there you go yeah he brings
his friends james gunn and tarantino are
like that
two directors who i can think of were
they like you want to show up for like a
second yeah i'm like sure
sure yeah i got i got an afternoon
despair why not what do you need me for
where are you shooting at
let's see here
i'm glad starro wasn't the real villain
but u.s government
i thought that was that was a thing i
was surprised about that they were that
forward about being like the u.s
government's been funding some nasty
stuff but they want to cover it up and
that's the real villain of the movie
that's like oh we're getting we're
getting a little bit realier
yeah but the the in the context of how
it's done and it's not exactly a
surprising reveal no it's like to me i
wasn't like
whoa i'm like nice there's a reason
amanda waller is sending them in here
you know yeah
they're probably doing a cover-up yeah
you know
so it wasn't a surprise but it's it's
nice to hear
a comic book movie that can have a bit
of a political ink slant to it yeah
overthrowing communism
government or u.s government being bad
you know funding hostile regimes us
government would not want to help out
unethical uh yeah weapons and biology
experiments but without
being the takeaway of james gunch is
pushing his political opinions down my
throat oh yeah because it just comes
across as another aspect of a very
complicated little workhorse right right
yeah instead of being like let's stop
everything and make this the point you
know
i could i think like michael mark in the
chat to say mongol had like no screen
time and i feel like for any of these
characters who did die
especially in the beginning
the dc multiverse has been well
established for a while now
points come in
no we don't even need flashpoint might
just help make it a little bit clearer
in terms of seeing some type of weird
thread yeah which is just a sci-fi
lines scripts
in the lines yeah
but i don't think uh i think they could
still appear in something they could
they could just come as a different
character in something else yeah you
know what i mean yeah
so that's about it i got i'm not i
wasn't bummed by any deaths because even
if i like even on hbo max because i saw
this twice in theaters and i want to
watch this a little bit of hbo max
they say in their ad like they have like
a compilation of dc films
that play before that plays before the
suicide squad and they reference it as
the dc multiverse
so
like if there's a character here like
mongol or uh black guard or whatever
javelin and you're like i want them to
come back
they they still can even boomerang can
come back yeah and
some offset in a different world and you
know what i mean well and the more that
they clarify their universe i think the
and the more steady it gets and the more
it has a chance to expand i think you
would have better opportunities like i
don't know what the ultimate it's only
the second suicide squad movie this is a
bit of a course correction but like you
could i feel like for this even just go
with that anthology like let's just mix
up some different characters and hey
maybe a couple of them maybe this is in
the past and a couple of them are in
another movie and you know they probably
won't die here but we'll still use them
interestingly like you know that would
yeah it feels like you could still if
anybody does a good enough portrayal or
any characters beloved enough they could
come back at some point
oh michael did not like the milton gag
oh buddy i'm sorry
let's we'll cut it out for you in the
hbo cut all right really quick we got a
couple of more super chats that did pop
up in here soupy sales
oh joe what did i do i did everything
you opened up the chat menu
oh as long as this movie is better than
the new 2016 version
yes it is
i think almost objectively although i
saw one comment in our in our review or
somewhere maybe even in this chat saying
that they they drastically preferred the
original
16 version so you know they're out there
if you're uh if you're feeling lonely
you know search around let's see here
tristan i had to mute you buddy
all right where are we at
renee renee carol is that right yeah
renee carroll
hi from chicago love you guys we love
you renee i really appreciate you being
here
thank you
dark jedi
knight
when king sharks split that guy in half
and the camera went slow-mo all i could
think of was king shark wins flawless
victory
he did get the mortal kombat kills like
the one where he chops that guy's head
off and then the head's in the mouth
yeah yeah he does get the moral combat
death
thank you dark jedi knight oh dude
i'll dlc character let's do this
mortals would be a cool dlc character in
mortal kombat i'd be down for that yeah
and it would perfectly work in that
world supernaturally speaking thank you
leon the sleepy that's really kind
comment
jay
shea born
hey guys fan of the show i don't know
i loved the movie but i don't uh like
them killing flag plus they made cena
unlikable flag's last words thoughts i
really did not
suspect justice for flag this would be
the most talked about thing during this
livestream i did not think this would be
the most disgusting
i wonder if they even expected that it
makes me happy
because
rick flagg was someone who was shat on
terms when you look back at the other
suicide squad movie but people really
like him here i'm really happy for that
and
i do remember james gone putting out
some tweet way before the movie was
released
of uh there's this character who dies in
and every time i watch it i cry oh i
think he was just based off the tweet i
had i felt like he was he's after
watching the movie i feel like he's
talking about rick flag i feel like yeah
he would have to death that would
warrant that emotional response i
thought yeah that or polka dot man but i
feel like but the
flag death has a little bit more breath
to it yeah so you know i feel like that
would be the one it feels the most
personal and it is like a truly
heartbreaking moment and he goes out you
know to the like i think his last line
is great yeah that his last dying breath
he he sends one more jab under his skin
you know what a joke
yes
but um
where are we at right here uh yeah i
mean i i
we've talked about it quite a bit
already here on the live stream uh but i
didn't think it made cena unlikable i
mean yeah
unlikable in that moment but when i
watched it the second time
i still really like peacemaker a lot and
you're not supposed to like him in that
moment i don't think you're supposed to
agree with him well maybe you are
someone who agrees with people maybe you
maybe you are the one who does
um
but
i
i wonder it does make me wonder what
they're gonna do with his character in
the show considering
the downward trajectory the perspective
takes on peacemaker here
where he ultimately is cast in a
villainous shadow
um by the end of this film
they don't really make it an equal
debate you know it's he's putting a
villainous shadow here
of what will they do with his character
in the news in the show that he's in
like will they rewrite him i know james
gunn worked on it directly too so i'm
like are they what would they change
about him is he gonna
learn about the black and white
territory
versus
it all has to be this one way about make
keeping it peaceful you know yeah
so
yeah i don't know i don't know i'm
curious too and i think the one thing is
you know
especially i feel like in long-running
comic book stories with anti-heroes and
and whatnot uh there is a certain
i don't know just narrative heft in
taking a character who's a bit
challenging and then you know pretty
soon like a weird example for this
particular movie but you know you think
of a devil's reject scenario and like
those are terrible people but after you
know
you know 25 minutes of you know table
turning all of a sudden you feel a way
about them that you didn't think you
necessarily would and i feel like you
know somebody like peacemaker uh there
are so many things you can point to even
characters where you're like
this character was on the down and then
they got powered up awesome oh [ __ ] now
they're confident again and giving in to
their worst inclinations so like there's
anything that good storytelling can do
to make a character like that more
interesting and i feel like you know
they hint at the part of peacemaker that
is sinister and that you prob most
people probably wouldn't be down with
throughout the movie it's not just there
you know so when it comes out you're
like i can see it you know i would
rather weasel get his own show michael
in the chat
uh kiefer grundmann brady thank you
again bud
do you guys have a desire to see an air
cut yeah i do i i feel like it would be
right
to see it yeah i'm not saying it's going
to be great you know like snyder cut was
it was one where i'm like i'm pretty
sure that would be pretty awesome yeah
i'm pretty confident about that
especially if you like zack snyder's
stuff yeah
and especially after seeing this movie
you know
james gunn has been very open about how
he really feels like wb let him have the
creative liberties he whatever he wanted
to do they let him do he's been pretty
open about how the one thing they
inquired him with about is maybe
including harley quinn but they also
gave him the option to not do it they
just would like her i don't know if it
was like a pressure situation uh maybe i
feel like any time they're asking that
you might feel it but james guns are
professional enough for this amount of
time anyway he said he wanted to write
for hurley yeah and he clearly enjoyed
writing for harvey i think so
with that in mind
it's like he got to do his suicide squad
he it was like i believe his words that
he was able to fulfill his vision
yeah we did get snyder cut james gunn
gets to do it and it's i i also firmly
believe
what david ayer has said about that's
not his edit
it's really obvious when you like watch
that first trailer which feels more like
a david ayer film yeah and then you
watched the movie and then how the
trailers progressed and then hearing
about the trailer companies i came in to
edit it and really rework it in terms of
reacting to what fans were saying about
like bvs at the time and all that
i don't know if the air cut would be
good or not i like my i'm really up in
the air about it of maybe it is maybe it
isn't i'm more like
i just think it's right i just think
it's fair to let him to just for us to
see it it's become such a thorn over
time and it's becoming 30 million
dollars into it
that's the trouble right but it is like
so much work and it is like so easy to
see when you look at that movie that
like a lot of things were this was not
how this was originally intended to be
and it does seem like one of a few
remaining sort of loose ends that yeah
it would just feel right to kind of have
completed in some way
plus i don't know maybe that will
strengthen your brand that much more
teague
ooh what other properties would you like
to see gun adapt i would like to see
twisted metal you could definitely do
twisted metal guys if you'd hit that
like button that'd be great yeah what
other properties is a twist of metal
would be good i was on john campbell
show recently and i really pitched swamp
thing i think he'd be doing an amazing
swamp thing film
like slither if you guys haven't seen
slither
do yourself a favor watch james gun
slither you know it's pretty awesome
and it's it's got some of that b-movie
schlock to it with uh
but it's also really inventive and
really it's a really it's like a pure
james gun film in a lot of ways and it's
got a lot of body horror a lot of sci-fi
horror
and i feel like swamp thing
is actually a really cool character
that his whose villains often involve
like crazy scientists and um
god i can't remember the villain's name
right now
sorry guys but
it's been a weird morning and i've been
trying not to bring that up all day
so wait 90 minutes of the last year
it's kind of been a chaotic morning for
me and normally i do a lot to prep my
mind
well i need to remember it i'm thinking
art jason woodrow that's not it it's the
uh what is the other i i don't remember
one of his main villains is like a
scientist who creates the unmen
and also has uh magic abilities some
necromancy abilities and swamp thing i
think would lend itself
properly to james gunn's sensibilities i
feel like naturally when you say
james gunn you might think oh justice
league dark you know do an ensemble or
something like that
and while i feel like yeah that's kind
of his thing he does the ensemble game
i think doing swamp thing would be just
more interesting to me and i feel like
he'd be able to really commit to the
horror of it but also bringing some of
that fantastical sci-fi horror whimsy
and maybe even deal with some magic
considering that's what swamp thing
often goes up against
uh so yeah i think swamp thing would be
cool i didn't watch i've only seen
segments of swamp thing homeboy reacted
i've only seen segments of the show
swamp thing which had some awesome
practical effects it was like really
good have you seen any of it
and only the ads it's we're some really
good practical
things that really make you think of the
of the show the thing i think of the
movie the thing john carpenter's and
that was surprisingly the
the aesthetic and the violence to it was
surprisingly really good from the
segments i've seen but i haven't seen
the show itself but i do think james
gunn could would nail a swamp thing uh
but yeah i mean is there a dc one you
like to see him do
another dc it's funny um
i don't know if i could think of another
dc weirdly the first thing that came to
mind
conker's bad for uh the first thing that
came to my mind and it's kind of a
low-hanging fruit but i mean i think it
would be super fun to see what james
gunn would do with a deadpool movie like
if he comes back finishes guardians i
feel like that's the next place at
marvel where i could be excited about
james gunn's expression
uh or like i don't know because then you
just go yeah like justice league dark or
something like that or you know i feel
like i feel like deadpool would always
be ryan reynolds movie
yeah
it would but i feel like if anybody
could maybe
maybe like truly be a another presence
that you could feel in the even more
people say take a white td all the time
and i feel like
more so like i get it for the humor's
sake but for the true breadth of
weirdness and strangeness of that world
like i feel like he would would dunk
that
pretty hard i don't want them to do some
people are pitching doom patrol in the
chat i wouldn't want them to do a dune
patrol movie because the show is
incredible
like flash show seems to be kind of on a
downward trajectory for audiences i even
completely fell off of it
and while i think james gov would
absolutely
just
do an amazing
doom patrol film
i i want people to go to the show right
now and i don't think people are going
to the show enough if you haven't seen
the doom patrol show it's one of the
best things dc has ever done it is
[ __ ] awesome it is bonkers and yeah i
can i cannot i've talked about it quite
a bit and and i i really
i really don't know how well that every
time it's picked up for another season
i'm like thank god because i don't hear
people really talk about this show i
would like to see james gunn's league of
extraordinary gentlemen
yeah that'd be fun that i would actually
want to to see try and happen because
that falls under the dc umbrella right
alan moore and yeah and alan moore would
never watch that i know but if anybody
could make it maybe good i feel like
maybe james gunn could do that pavin
meyer tyrone didn't like it this guy has
no taste
uh i wouldn't say that it is subjective
it's subjective man you know like i can
understand you being upset and it bums
me out that he didn't like it because i
feel like lately tyrone and i just know
the same page about movies anymore
you can't go to the theater lived in
opinions uh and i thought we might even
feel the same about black widow like
this guy's like black widow a lot more
than that
so uh yeah it's it's kind of interesting
how uh lately i'm hoping he really likes
free guide because i want everyone to
watch freak that's
the last
stand right there
but no it's just different opi you know
it's like you can't
fault someone for the way they feel the
way someone feels is the way they feel
and they can't control that
um you know and sometimes it can be uh
hearing
the you know a deeper opinion piece
to maybe
enhance or i don't even say enhance that
sounds like i'm putting down someone's
opinion or or persuade someone's opinion
that's happened with me before it
doesn't happen often but it has happened
with me where i'm like
you know i never looked at it that way
and then when i go back and watch it i
see it through that lens that's kind of
what was probably happening with bvs for
me was i would hear like the in-depth
opinions not just you suck snyder rocks
like out here like
the in-depth opinions about it
and i'm like i never really viewed it
and then when i would go back i would
start with kind of that angle to see if
i could see it from there and then i
would formulate more opinions now and
add on to that
and so
yeah but i wouldn't you know if someone
doesn't like it
it's really reviews are a funny game i
feel like
i feel like red letter media
and generally cosmonaut variety hour
are really they have this good fan base
where
if they have the unpopular opinion
they're not going to be stormed with
hate or dislikes you know
it's and it's cool to be that like we're
not there uh
yeah you know but we don't have a fan
base that really echoes our direct
sentiments yeah and i have like you know
uh uh what is it there's um you know
like i don't think even beyond the
trailer even has that you know
so
that's just but the reality is is like
it you just gotta be honest and
sometimes you don't have the pop you
don't have you know your opinion is not
in line with what the majority think and
you kind of just gotta be honest and and
a lot of the time too people have made
up their minds whether or not they're
gonna love it or not yeah you know so i
don't know i'm the kind of person who
i always just look at what they're
saying and if i can respect it then then
then i'll upvote you
i rarely i've never i don't think i've
actually hit the down vote on a video
before and so i i'll just leave the
video i won't hit the downvote yeah i
appreciate a a an opinion very different
from mine especially on on something
like this yeah exactly because it only i
don't know it's that it's that old
argument like it only serves to make
your own opinions stronger or or you
know test your own you know sort of uh
critical thinking of surrounding
whatever thing
ooh james gunn doing a spawn you know
it's gonna start off oh on last night
the hbo show that's a good call i
haven't seen the spawn show and i was
like maybe you react to this i don't
know i should have said that but uh a
spawn show would be a judge dread movie
would be pretty neat i saw ninja turtles
that would be cool
uh let's see r-rated ninja turtles this
is gonna make him gross
makes splinter gross
michael keaton as condiment king sean
gomez calendar man in there
yeah i mean he's the guy who calls a
polka dot man a [ __ ] yeah calendar man
yeah you could tell by the
writings on his face by the orange
jumpsuit yeah and his baldness yeah
did he have like writing like there were
things in there that made me think
that's gotta be calendar man oh i gotta
go look at his face again you you are
probably correct
jenna channel the great i don't did we
done i thought we got his super chat
didn't we what let's go down we don't
miss super let's just go down anyone we
don't
oh we did miss
there you are we [ __ ] up apparently
you're totally right you're currently
watching it now
all that defending like what are you
talking about you're you are an idiot we
totally messed up channel the great so
sorry okay
chanel
currently watching it now
so i just wanted to stop in and say
what's up you guys all right i'm out i
don't want to hear no spoilers well it's
been a while what did you think yeah did
you finish it or did you just finish it
and then check in
enjoy the movie
really
you know
god it was
every movie that i've seen this year
that has had a dual release
squad was the only one where i'm like
damn it
i wish this wasn't coming out streaming
you know if some people say about like
godzilla versus kong or black widow and
i respect that
uh but the one that really generated the
feeling for me
was
was suicide squad of like oh damn now
i'm gonna feel what all those theaters
and studios are feeling just like why
the [ __ ] did you do this and regardless
of the performance now i'm just going to
be focused on did streaming have
anything to do with that
i mean seeing how many people are
talking about this seeing how many
people like uh i
i i expecting that it's done incredibly
well on hbo max i completely believe
that yeah
i
and it's not it's underperforming at the
box office currently who knows maybe
today there'll be some like random surge
um that's happened before it's like
friday's kind of dead but then
saturday's like really rich and alive
uh but yeah i mean i wish more people
would you know watch this in the theater
i'm trying to show my theater support
more i just bought tickets again for
free guy oh yeah because i'm like you
know i gotta watch free guy again i want
to see that on imax you know one pin i'm
like and then i open it up like no one's
put tickets for free
well that's the hardest damn it that was
the heartening and sure
might make a huge difference or chongqi
too he's coming out too that was the
thing yesterday as i was searching
around because yeah i was like i
it just i felt like the yeah the go back
to the theater is probably the right way
to do this and i looked on the amc i
didn't go to amc because the screenings
were so heavily sold oh for a suicide
squad yeah that's very cool that i wound
up
john save us save us bring us back to
the light
i i wound up i wound up purchasing a
ticket at the lemley because i could at
least get a little bit of space from
people but even then that was a pretty
well attended screening so it was
heartening to me it seemed like you know
because because lately in the in the few
opportunities i've had to like look in
the app and be like what movies are
playing what tickets are there usually
stuff is wide open yeah so uh
hopefully it picks up
you know what i would also add to the
film really quick so i'm seeing people
finally talking about the
we start our comment we might not always
like go directly to read a comment and
then completely rip off that but the
subjects of what guide our discussion
are based off of what's going on in the
chat usually
what i'll say to you about
what did you think about with heart i
want to bring this back to the movie
again really quick
um what did you think about uh
um
harley having her own side story
and then how would a ties
because i the first time i watched it i
remember thinking it felt like it might
have been
slowing down a little too much for me
when she's like
talking with the dictator and then
romancing with him and stuff
eventually it really like i was like
once she shoots him and has that
monologue i was really digging it yeah
absolutely yeah um
i loved her like that delivery on the
dial honestly
harley is usually so
you know she's always been psychotic
crazy loony whatever that word you want
to apply uh but
that scene to me was the most unnerving
of any of her actual like real acting
scenes that she's done in any of the
movies yeah of like this is an icky
scene to watch this is weird she just
had sex with this guy and shot him and
rolling through a pool and the tone of
it is just so unsettling to me yeah and
uh she's like apologizing for him and
she's like but you look better this way
so beautiful that is the first
time i felt that uncomfortable feeling
in my heart of
oh this is this is kind of the harley i
wanted yeah to be this uncomfortable
with her with a just a dialogue scene
you know without all those ugly thoughts
it felt
it felt like in in the insanity the
provocative nature of her character in
all the right ways yeah so
there's so much that seems to be the
thing that has such a the two debates
that i am that the two debates that i'm
seeing happen with this movie
have to do with just they really have
killed off everyone at the beginning and
the handling of harley quinn and i i
gotta say um yeah i think the handling
harley quinn was cool and i
i loved kind of like the
fantasy nature the movie provides to it
this almost destiny tone to it
where at the end like
they set her up or she has that scene
with javelin she hands off the javelin
the javelin keeps coming back to her you
know like like it's drawn to her like in
the fight scene when she breaks out it
comes back to her yeah i love how she
just tucks it into the cab so smoothly
through the window
and then uh when when the tower is
collapsing
that the shot with polka dot man bloods
for her running yeah and she sees the
challenge
yeah yeah yeah
well that's like it's it's the perfect
little magical cartoon beat and i and it
ties like i don't know i i
yeah i get i feel like any time you talk
about this story you have to be like i
get how it could seem sort of like a
side quest but to me especially taking
the javelin bit and the fact that she
and flag are the two that get off the
beach like it spoke to me
to again this movie does have a sort of
anthological kind of pacing to me and so
you know there are lots of things
happening in a lot of different places
there are a lot of moving parts and you
know what harley is doing still has to
do with the situation it's still in part
of the center of the conflict and it
does have an effect on the overall plot
and it also is on their way to getting
everybody to where they need to be so to
me
like i again it's another choice
that feels like in some way you can
count on it being a little more divisive
it's not a choice for everybody but to
me i was like yeah i like that you know
it it makes a little bit of sense that
at least one of these characters would
be isolated for a little bit of time and
we'll use that as a means to do
something for that character but also
something a little different and you
know harley as a character has her own
world to exist in so it it felt
appropriate to me but i wouldn't
necessarily tell you you're wrong for
maybe uh feeling like it
uh uh could have been handled
differently or or could have been paced
differently or something like that
oh yeah true
oh [ __ ] we did the exact thing i was
worried about what's that did the exact
thing where i was like
we got us we can't start making
sometimes we start making points and
then super chat comes in and i'm like oh
crap we could have reserved that point
for when the super chat came in because
we're also going off of what's going on
in just another regular live stream chat
too doing our best i didn't monitor this
well enough
charles harkins said did you see harley
killing that dictator coming because i
didn't monologue callback efforts made
my low key favorite team well we just
talked about that significantly but i
will say what i'm going to add to it is
i did not see that coming no absolutely
not that was uh a moment where she shot
him that actually
surprised me yeah
and and she just banged exactly and at
the moment of the gunshot you're not
even sure who did it so yeah like
there's a double reveal there of like oh
it's her
because i thought she did it because i'm
like it's the mission
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i love that too
like i didn't even think this gun would
have been
uh but thank you for the super chat but
alto voltej
the fact cena is a figure for little
kids and you have him cursing and
blowing [ __ ] up brings a tear to my head
a big grin in my face
captain america right there i love how
much john cena has embraced this you
know going to doing like
interviews and then going to the
premiere
of dressed up as peacemaker wearing the
actual costume just how committed he is
to it
um that's just smart to me yeah that's
really smart it just makes it that much
more fun it's more shareable it's gonna
get more people talking about the movie
it's funny because he's not even
he's not in character as peacemaker he's
just dressed up as he's just cosplaying
his piece he's not doing what uh you
know will ferrell does
when he's like ron burgundy you know
he's not doing that or or um uh sasha
baron cohen he's just dressed up as
peacemaker but just you know just john
cena just didn't just hit my piecemaker
outfit this is how i hang out yeah it's
not a toilet seat it's a beacon of
chillaxin
uh liben alley
ooh
since we are talking about james gunn
adapting properties i would really like
to see him try his hands at ghost rider
that would be uh pretty funny different
there'd be a different swing and it
would probably be yeah a turn into
something maybe a bit tonally darker you
know i'm sure there would still be humor
but not quite as much i think you could
kind of feed into the demented nature
that ghost rider brings oh yeah and the
hellish yeah i mean like you can make
mephisto hilarious yeah
be played by christopher wyatt
chad the grape thank you for reminding
us i hope you enjoyed the movie buddy i
think we got a couple a little uh what
do we got here yeah yeah yeah a little
stream labs we want to refresh that are
we up to date we're up to date all right
all right all right what's going on here
we are
right here is over all right
jay bizzle i love the show guys would
anyone see the second stinger know that
flag is alive and in the hospital flag
is alive and in the hospital that's
you're a troll my friend
you're a troll
that scene just keeps going and they
keep walking down the hall of flags
alive oh we're gonna need
this guy's alive we're gonna need him
hey we put savant's head back together
we're gonna need him okay
here we go
boomerang's arm we were able to regrow
his body he's alive
popcorn
uh can we ask questions not related to
the movie yeah you can ask question
related movie i found you all because of
the schmoedan will you be attending the
live event thanks
uh
i don't know
is there's live events is there's an
email we missed
i thought there was just some kind of
event i missed many emails from the
showdown if there's a live event uh
that's a big old maybe yeah it depends
on where it is uh
it depends on how long maybe how the
city is doing
are we wanted at schmodown events i
don't know if we would be there like you
you're wanted yeah
but you you but you're greg man but
you're john you're gray
[Laughter]
rat man carried the whole movie
woo rap man
where's my rat man t-shirt no one's been
talking about rap man
no one's talked about rap man or any of
the rats really shouts out to sebastian
and all of his many brothers and sisters
and otherwise
you know batman one two three four in
the chat uh it said i literally turned
to my cousin the moment javelin gave
harley and said that javelin's gonna
save the day and it [ __ ] happened
javelin is the real hero
i really thought it was cool
when harley was like these are my
friends
i thought it was cool
how
they all had a chance to showcase their
abilities and work as a unit and you do
see visually before anyone's like he's
leading uh tim let's work to say he
he starts leading i love the shot that's
like following him kind of looks like an
anime shot like hardly jumping up on the
roof and stuff so i i really appreciate
those moments um
but i really love that shot when uh
harley climbs up on the wall puts the
javelin on you have sorrow's eye and
you're like oh that's cool yeah it's
like
it's showing you it's like james gunn's
letting you know no she's going to use
the javelin to pierce through his eyes
yeah yeah and the shot just tells you
that's what's going to happen you know
well and that's another thing about you
know the way the opening is handled is
like that's an element that makes
javelin feel kind of still present to me
anyway even though he's not there you
know it makes that character presence
feel like it lingered beyond the opening
ah
man i want to do well people keep asking
about
all right
guys we're going to wrap up the stream
in just a little bit i don't know how
much time we're going on here but it's
going a while yeah
almost at two hours getting close
let's see here
uh
okay yeah it's gonna wrap up the last of
these super chats here but thank you to
all who have contributed so far fun it's
nice to be back on the live
let's bring this back
name's not milton that's going to be you
know that's going to be uh
he says that's not my name
that's what bloodsport says yeah
he says not my name yeah yeah not my
name not my name that's gonna be a great
gift
yeah that's gonna be a great gift
michael de souza you can become a patron
if you want you can absolutely it's the
choice is yours
choice is yours that's how our patreon
should be set up
do we want you
go through it and approve i want you to
be a patreon check to get into our
patreon hyper surveys
yeah would you submit a blood test
please
mr vaju ooh
missed you guys i watched it in theaters
yes
was a little disappointed
oh should have watched on hbo max would
have loved it then you would have loved
it man liked it not loved it good not
great enjoyed it more at home third best
dc eu movie nice dang
okay that's fair hey hey we take all
comers here it's good to hear from you
mister
fear and loathing and thank you mr about
you yeah we respect your opinion buddy
it's okay now get the hell out of here
yeah or if you want to contribute again
go for fear and loathen
um in general
in general that's a great name
james gunn doing a green lantern film
but shot like cops hal john kyle and guy
and we're riding along with them what
the [ __ ] that would be so why would you
need james gunn for that yeah
just the premise alone is the star of
that [ __ ] i don't know james come to do
that i just want to see what a pitch of
that looks like please with full cgi
that'd be funny though i would like it
zack snyder's cops
glad people are championing the theater
experience in the chat right now
life of night as much as i enjoy the
guardians of the galaxy movies i enjoyed
james gunn the suicide squad more also
this movie makes me like rick flagg i
would second these statements i
i would have to revisit them but i think
i
for my personal taste
i would say i like them more than
because there's so much more i'm
factoring in than maybe a lot of other
people are
like i i you could just really tell that
this is just his movie yeah you know
where the guardians is like it's james
gone through but it's also like a lot of
marvel input it's a big it's a great
part of a bigger plan it's amazing top
tier mcu and i i love i love they're
easily top the first one is top mcu
films for me
um
but this just felt more like a pure film
to me
you know oh yeah oh absolutely and i
mean it goes to weirder
somewhat weirder emotional places
especially and it trudges greater depths
i think yeah yeah
sarah campbell just joined the live
haven't seen the movie haven't decided
if i will just saying hey boys hope
you're doing well sarah campbell we are
doing well
and as someone like you who doesn't
watch comic book movies ever um i would
watch this one and then let it set an
expectation for you that all comic book
movies are like this
yes that'll all be in the in the guise
of a 70s action thriller is this what
ant-man and the wasp is like wow this is
grittier this is cooler than i would
have thought this was for children yeah
no it's good
i'm gonna watch fantastic four directed
by tim's story now
yeah followed straight up with rise of
the silver star
oh and peter pacheco you're ending off
our super chats of the day buddy
appreciate it man
appreciate ya
good job greg when you were on campia
show
hey thanks
yeah have you seen new rocks hurricanes
are you tipping in on the camping shows
the other day they've seen new rockstars
easter eggs
that's up next that's very uh
we we did it while we're live streaming
yeah this is all pre-recorded which
you've been watching [ __ ] all you guys
over here but the reaction to the easter
eggs tomorrow morning will be performed
live yeah yeah
nothing else it seems it would be it
could be there's gotta be a way to do
that one day though it's possible
without doing a live stream a live
stream easter egg you rock stars and
watch us
it's it's possible in obs make sure we
we commit everything to memory all those
times that we cut that i cut out of the
videos and i'm like wait what was the
name of that guy again
yeah
wait go back what the hell did eric vos
just said
have a few times
what is this theory are you talking
about now
yeah yeah no we're gonna watch it today
that was a plan do our spoiler talk it's
all part of the plan and then
and then this is just more enjoyable to
do spoiler talk this way yeah and then
we get to exactly what you want to know
we covered everything you guys wanted
all right
guys let's do a speed round here in the
live stream before we cap this off
you've got two minutes with us chat time
two minutes two minutes minutes of three
minutes
three minutes of pizza pizza
just like peeing for three straight
minutes did he say pete time to play
time oh but he crunches it yeah
i'm quoting spider-man yeah what does he
say
i thought i thought it was play time but
he says play time i thought it was pete
time it's the way he says it it does
kind of psych what's his name uh
bone saw is ready boone saw right
it was uh randy savage right wasn't that
macho man randy savage live streams for
us do not work well in the algorithm
because we rarely do them
you know live streams like for ours go
really well if it's like
like an insane tall like we did snyder
cut that was like 1500 people were
watching consistently that whole time
yeah it was huge and it even accumulated
in views
significantly oh yeah
yeah this is like a random
uh it's very different from mcu films
graham and we love you
three minutes of play time
uh hello to nigeria
they're apples and oranges with the mcu
films i haven't seen batman the long
halloween part one and part two i did
watch
batman
um
uh
[ __ ] the one where they changed the
hush
batman hutch
and that was uh interesting to say the
least
it was okay
there's things about it i liked but
there's some pretty awful things in
there too
versus seed i will absolutely hold your
javelin angela sanchez what a great
question you could introduce
poison ivy in the swamp thing movie dude
when do you think poison ivy would
introduce yeah do it man yeah i i'm
surprised
get amber hurt
no wait
get jamie lynn's spears no wait wait
wait wait
get britney's pair
wait i get her whole conservatorship to
play poison ivy together or they can
just all play the swamp thing
vineeth thanks for being here silent
enjoy gaming we're gonna work on the uh
the suicide squad we'll put it up
tomorrow morning
marley was disappointed hush michael i
answered your question you can become a
patreon man oh i need to see your dm i
guess to see what's going on honored
armist is poison ivy then ben affleck
will be like you got to get me back in
there leah kim
bang both jennifer lopez
and jennifer garner get her in there as
well i want to see bloodsport return for
sure marley leah kim 98 just wanted to
send you some love i'm glad we're able
to bring you a little bit of joy mahan
shouts out from iron iran
hey shouts to iran angela sanchez said
wait
why
wait for what wait for a pregnant pause
a dramatic bit of suspense
uh
gabe thank you for being here buddy
that's true der joy b there's your boys
see you didn't care if you let the
characters you don't care about movies
that is an absolutely true statement you
gotta care about the character how the
[ __ ] did he know
all the all that in-depth bullshitting
we did for so long
all it comes down to is it's good
because you cared he picked up on how
big of frauds we are ah you said what we
couldn't say in
short that the world they should do a
catwoman cinematic universe arkham red
halle berry and hathaway whoever played
her in lego batman uh yeah i got a
michelle pfeiffer bag
uh
[Music]
randy savage around macho man yeah
if they were to do another suicide squad
movie
who would you guys want james cunn
directed absolutely yeah
um mr vaiju of course we're still
friends it's okay that you don't like
the movie
yeah i'm sure they did not say we're
some kind of suicide squad i'm glad they
didn't say that
jeremy you found us through superman and
lois oh thank you so much coming back
next week
along with what it is maria thank you so
much all right guys it's time for harley
to get all lesbian with pause
it's time let's get it through it
all right why was necessary to shoot a
naked dude in the jungle because they
thought he was a bad guy they thought he
had a weapon
look at that thing oh no
biggest threat there all right guys
thank you so much for being here this
was fun this is really relaxing and
enjoyable and hey we'll uh chat about
we'll catch you guys soon keep a lookout
for a reaction new rockstars breakdown
see you guys peace
now end the stream john aye aye capitan
and the stream get the hell it's time to
go
uh three
two
one
we're still live yeah so what the hell
is going on we're still live for five